Riverdale always keeps us on the edge of
our seats with it's scary wild
storylines but sometimes storylines just
don't make any sense
check out these 10 potholes from
Riverdale without left us hanging I've
got a job for you Jones I want you to
find out who shot my father
quarantine what quarantine
one of the major plots early on in
season 3 was the outbreak people are
falling victim to some sort of disease
they are having seizures and worse and
it appears to be highly contagious the
school shuts down all extracurricular
activities it closes the student lounge
and then a whole bunch of people get
rounded by men in hazmat suits they are
rounding up the infected it keeps
getting worse
Penelope pushes for the high school to
be shut down as more and more kids are
experiencing seizures this is a pretty
serious outbreak where are the
government agencies that take care of
this sort of stuff Hyrum says he called
the CDC but they didn't care that's not
how things work in real life at all
Penelope talks about tracking down
patient zero and running tests on them
but none of them are really qualified
for that hyrum eventually convinces the
mayor to put Riverdale under quarantine
of course this is all part of Hiram's
great plan but then the quarantine just
doesn't happen it seems like a huge deal
but in the next episode it's already
over
they say the crime rate has risen during
the quarantine but that's really good
the quarantine was already lifted if it
was a huge part of Hiram's plan why
didn't it last the twin eight problem
there are two sets of twins in Riverdale
and they both have some pretty big
issues with their age let's start with
Jason and Cheryl they are twins the show
mentions the fact that they are twins
quite often but they never seem to be in
the same grade in fact it's hard to tell
what grade they are in at all in season
one Cheryl is in the same grade as Betty
Archie and Veronica that made her a
sophomore good I'm guilty it also
mentioned that Jason was in the same
grade as Polly when he was killed
we don't know exactly how old Polly is
but we know she's older than Betty
that means Jason is at least a junior or
senior sure maybe Jason skipped a grade
or two or May
Cheryl got held back but then Cheryl
sometimes seems a lot older in season
one she was cheer captain
that's not something sophomores get to
do very often but if she was a sophomore
in the first season then she would be a
senior in season three yet they never
mentioned her upcoming graduation what
gives it makes no sense if someone
skipped a grade or got held back why
isn't it mentioned the other twins are
Polly's kids juniper and Dagwood haven't
aged at all they should be at least
walking by now so many gangs so few
people Riverdale is not that big of a
town everyone seems to know everyone
there are only two high schools now at
first the only game we know about is the
Serpent's and that makes sense
lots of towns have gangs now the thing
about gangs is that they often have turf
wars
this means that gangs control different
parts of towns they'll fight over
controlling different areas they usually
get a lot of their power from dealing
illegal substances and the serpents
definitely do that but then in season
three there are all these new gangs
they're the Ghoulies one of the biggest
rivals of the serpent's then there are
the pretty poisons which is an all-girl
gang and let's not forget the gargoyle
gang they're going to be a big issue in
season four we're pretty sure we aren't
sure Riverdale really understands what
gangs are we could understand having a
whole bunch of different crime groups in
a large city but Riverdale is a small
town in the middle of nowhere does that
mean everyone is a gang member it seems
like it's easier to start a gang in
Riverdale than an after-school Club the
blue-eyed problem the black hood is the
main antagonist in the second season of
Riverdale a lot of the show is spent
trying to figure out who the real black
hood is and it was a wild ride
we were totally shook when we found out
that how Cooper was really behind it but
there is a huge problem with the black
hood killer all of the clues early on
revolve around the killer having green
eyes in fact the show makes a huge deal
about the black hood having green eyes
it continues even after a man is framed
and caught we even see a close-up photo
of the black hood his eyes are
definitely green jack head is pretty
sure they caught the wrong guy and he
was right the green eyed killer was
still out there but then we find out the
truth it was how Cooper all along but
how Cooper definitely has blue eyes
there is no mistaking his eye color
sure maybe how put on green contacts
before every murder it would definitely
distract from his real identity but if
he did the show doesn't mention it why
would they make a big deal about the
killer had been green eyes if how has
blue eyes it seems like a huge oversight
the Cooper family secrets the blosum
family is one of the oldest families in
Riverdale a hundred years ago or so they
settled in Riverdale and founded their
maple syrup business but then drama
struck two of the early blossom brothers
had a major disagreement over profits in
the business and fights over money never
end well
one of the brothers killed the other and
then the family hated each other so much
they split half of the family broke all
ties and changed their name to Cooper
crazy right well pal and Alice were
aware of this secret your
great-grandfather wasn't just murdered
he was a blossom we don't know when the
Cooper family members get to learn the
truth but Polly and Betty were shocked
to learn it
paddlin Alice did not want Polly dating
Jason blossom but rather than tell her
the truth they let them continue dating
and then Polly got pregnant Jason was
her cousin and the father of her babies
yikes
how wanted Polly to get rid of the
babies but he still wouldn't tell her
the truth eventually though he had to
come clean it's been a hundred years
since the blossom family split we just
don't understand why it stayed a secret
for so long it makes no sense the gang
is the law a lot of the plot holes in
Riverdale involve the serpents this is
the gang that controls a lot of the
crime in town it's the gang that Jughead
was pressured to join by his father but
then things get really messed up FP
apparently turns his life around well
sort of but he does become the sheriff
of Riverdale sheriff Jones now boy
Riverdale has had some seriously
terrible sheriff's we'll talk more about
that later but Hermione Lodge appointed
him even though FP was a criminal he did
go to jail for murder after all but he
committed a lot more crimes than he was
convicted of sure the mayor was trying
to frame him but putting a criminal in
charge of law enforcement is not a good
way to do it
not to mention that Hermione's plan
totally backfired and that's what
happens when you lead a gang and then
the story gets crazier sheriff's can
deputize people to help them enforce the
law FP deputizes the serpent's he uses
them to help with the drug problem yes
that's right a gang that used to sell
illegal substances now has the power to
enforce the law they can even arrest
people this is more than corrupt it just
makes no sense at all what's even
crazier is that FB is probably the best
sheriff they've had how scary is that
teen leader okay we love Jacob Jones we
really do but we don't think it makes
any sense that he is the leader of the
serpents just hear us out
first of all Jughead really didn't want
to join the serpents for a long time but
once FP was put in jail Jack had decided
it was time the serpents could give him
protection so he underwent the
initiation process but he rose in the
ranks really quickly sure he is F piece
kid that made him kind of like a prince
in the game but that would never be
enough in the real world most adults
don't let teenagers boss them around
when you consider that the serpents are
all hardened criminals it seems even
more unlikely we just don't see a bunch
of experience to biker gang members
listening to some kid these gang members
have a lot more experience than Jughead
they're also older we have no idea how
Jack had gained their respect
something major had to have happened for
him to become the king but if it did the
show doesn't really mention it serpents
fashion the serpents are easily
recognizable by their cool leather
jackets but this is actually a serious
plot hole the whole thing about the
serpents is that they are poor they live
on the south side they don't have much
money at all in fact most of them lived
in a trailer park until it was blown up
now a lot of them live in tents but when
they get initiated they get a brand new
shiny leather jacket even Cheryl gets
one in red who is buying these jackets
the leaders of the gang aren't any
richer than the rest of the members and
most of the members are teenagers who
don't have jobs besides the game and
then there's Jughead
he's kind of a fashion icon he's got
that grunge look down pat but he's not
wearing cheap clothes just as jackets
cost over a hundred bucks
these aren't thrift store finds they're
stylish and new how does he afford these
clothes while we love the serpent
fashion statements it is totally
unbelievable we just think that the
show's creators could make the poor
characters seem more realistic to cool
for
cool alright we know that shows
featuring teenagers often overlooked the
whole school thing but Riverdale takes
this to the next level seriously if
there weren't actual scenes at the high
school we would never know they were
students and honestly how is anyone in
Riverdale learning there are masked
killers
there are huge drug problems and a bunch
of gangs there is a really powerful cult
that even infiltrates the school most of
the main characters have demanding jobs
outside of school
Jughead runs a gang Archie runs a gym
now Veronica runs restaurant and the bar
that's a whole other issue how is a teen
running a bar how do they have time to
go to school or do any homework and then
everyone stops what they're doing to
study and take the SATs
first of all cramming for a major test
means not going to work if you haven't
been studying all year but this just
seems so random if they are going to
neglect the school storyline it's weird
to randomly throw in tests it messed
with the whole flow of the season and we
really don't understand why any of the
characters suddenly cared about school
who needs law enforcement kids solving
mysteries is a tale as old as time it
worked for Nancy Drew and the Boxcar
Children and it seems to work for Betty
Cooper we love all the mysteries on
Riverdale they're intense and dark we
are always on the edge of our seats but
why is it always up to Betty and the
rest of the gang while law enforcement
in Riverdale is terrible at best they
are totally incompetent and corrupt at
worst it's absolutely a joke but sure
there are other vigilantes citizens who
want to solve crimes instead it all
falls to a bunch of teenagers and they
never call for backup
especially Betty she does all this
dangerous stuff by herself Riverdale is
basically in total anarchy it might as
well be the purge everyday of course
their new Sheriff used to lead a gang
nothing about the police in Riverdale
makes any sense we still love the show
though we can't wait to find out who the
gargoyle king is in season 4 what
potholes drove you crazy in Riverdale
let us know in the comments some things
on TV may not make sense but subscribing
to the things does hit that red button
for more great content see you next time
[Music]